i was fortunate enough to get my hands
on a review copy of the upcoming novel
tom clancy's the division recruited
i haven't done a book review before
other than required work in my days at
university but given my obsession with
the division story and the fact that
i've covered both of the previous books
in great detail i thought why not
written by thomas parrott i admittedly
was a little nervous when i first opened
this up as the previous two books had
been written by alex irvine and had
grown comfortable with his style of
writing and had no idea what to expect
from this new author's interpretation
however i was pleasantly surprised
[Music]
[Music]
the green poison epidemic that
originated in new york city has now
spread far and wide
washington dc was one of the next major
cities to be hit
much like new york it wasn't long before
dc's infrastructure began to collapse
police hospitals emergency services were
quickly overrun
the national guard was called in but was
unable to cope with the riots and
dwindling numbers through sickness
the government was falling apart and
what was left of it was evacuated from
the city the president has died and the
two who were appointed since have also
been reported as dead
however the sleeper cell agents of the
division are still active attempting to
save what remains
and despite their low numbers they have
been successful in pushing some of the
larger hostile groups back and out of
the city
although the identity and knowledge of
the shd's existence was among the
highest level of classified agencies it
has been months since the first wave was
activated and by this stage most people
have either witnessed or heard tales of
their activity across america
located in maryland mara kanghai is a
security expert who previously served in
the u.s navy
when things started getting bad she
rushed over to the enlistment officers
so she could do her part in helping
bring the situation back under control
but when she got there she realized it
was too late
the building was dark
all she found was a man in an officer's
uniform
slumped over the desk
he had clearly taken his own life rather
than succumb to the virus that was
ravaging the country
it was at this point that maya knew that
all she could do was to fall back and
ride out the situation at hand
to do her best to ensure that she and
her younger brother could survive
they would go on to move around from
building to building district to
district in search of a safe place that
they could call home
eventually they would join a community
of survivors
called athena
in time mara's past and the navy would
become known and much to her objections
she was placed in charge of athena's
security
protecting it from the scavengers and
hostile groups who only wanted to take
advantage of what was going on
unfortunately myra's time of head
security led to making some tough
decisions
some of these decisions required action
for the survival of the community
but would ultimately lead to the death
of members
including her own brother
one day while the team was returning
from a supply scavenging mission they
were followed by a large heavily armed
group wearing yellow hoods
myra's defensive preparations put up a
good fight but ultimately they were far
outgunned and quickly losing ground to
this invading group
fortunately for athena there just
happened to be a cell of division agents
who were active nearby
through a cloud of smoke and gunfire the
agents quickly dispatched the remaining
hostile forces
inside athena once the smoke had settled
myra talks with the agents
and finds out that they were actually
just passing through to carry out a
mission of grave importance
then before myra realizes what's
happening the next day she has agreed to
joining these agents in their mission
she doesn't exactly know what it is and
what she's signed up for but she's now
been given the chance to make a real
difference
the old way of recruiting agents is long
gone
the only way that new members can now be
recruited is out in the field
will myra be successful in overcoming
the tests and challenges thrown her way
or will she be overcome by the long line
of enemies who are plotting to put a
stop to the country's last line of
defense the division
thomas parrott has an amazing style of
writing
don't get me wrong i thoroughly enjoyed
the previous two novels written by alex
irvine
but this was something special
call me a classic stereotypical
millennial if you'd like but generally
i'm not so driven by fictional written
literature
i would usually prefer my fictional
entertainment to come in the form of
something interactive or with supporting
infographics images or even movies and
cutscenes
i prefer my general reading to go into
something that is more fact-based
learning education knowledge these are
the things that will generally drive my
reading experience
but parrot's work on this novel
absolutely hooked me in
sure there was a certain amount of
familiarity with the setting that drove
some of it
but the detail he went into when
describing scenes
i could picture in my head so clearly
that i struggled to put it down
i found myself hanging on to every word
actually it wasn't even so much the
detail i don't think that's the right
way of explaining it
the style and direction of how he
explained it it just met up with how my
imagination has been filling the gaps
with the division story up until now
i was so engaged that i found myself
reading through certain scenes faster to
match the action of what was playing out
in the story
and that i was actually feeling my heart
rate increase like i'd entered the dark
zone in the division 1 for the first
time
again i'm not familiar with the sort of
reaction through reading a book so bear
with me
a huge part of this has to be with how
the characters have been portrayed
all three of the main characters are
very easy to relate to
brenda the division's cell leader is
charismatic and strong but isn't without
her vulnerabilities and regrets about
the choices she has made in the past
leo is a strong silent type with a stoic
almost hostile way of expressing himself
to those around him
but deep down he is a heart of gold
trying his best to hide his utmost
respect and care for those in his team
while keeping the mission at the
forefront of his mind
and myra a strong but likable character
who like most others has gone through
absolute hell to survive this far
while she embraces a challenge ahead of
her at every turn she questions whether
she is capable either ethically morally
or physically
the story is told from myra's point of
view and although i thought i'd struggle
after following april callahar for so
long i found it a very easy transition
into her story
within only a few chapters i found
myself having formed quite a
relationship with each of them
the only thing about this novel that
didn't quite sit well with me was the
ending it just felt a little
anticlimactic
without going into detail it just sort
of ended
i don't know what i was expecting but i
wanted a little more
however this could be more of a
testament as to how much i was enjoying
the story rather than the ending being
no good
if you enjoyed the new york collapse and
broken door novels this book is for you
if i had to rank them i would say that
new york collapse was a bit different
due to all of the puzzles that needed to
be solved so it would be better to
compare it to broken dawn and out of the
two i found recruited to be far more
engaging
i'm actually looking forward to reading
through it again
don't get me wrong i like reading
fiction but i often find myself getting
bored with all the fluff they use to
fill the story and build the scene i
just never felt that way with this novel
am i just getting older and more chill
ready to embrace this sort of
entertainment
or is this a book that you really need
to check out
believe it or not i've kept the spoilers
to a minimum i've just attempted to set
the scene a bit more than the general
overview that were given on most
websites
the bulk of what i've talked about is
from early on in the book and there are
a number of details that are purposely
left out i'm not interested in spreading
any spoilers or leaks
i plan on covering the story in greater
depth after it's been released in
february 2022 but as always i'd
recommend reading the book as it will do
far greater justice to the story than i
will
i'll be tackling it from a narrative
point of view rather than through the
eyes of the agent and training
now for a hint of speculation i feel
like there may even be a little bit of a
teller as to why the fighting is
happening in the soon-to-be-released
division heartlands
the agents are headed in roughly the
right direction for this
so some of the events they came across
could be the reason
but i absolutely couldn't be sure
as there has been nothing officially
released on the upcoming title
that's something to talk about more in a
later video
thank you for watching i hope you've
enjoyed my first ever book review and
i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]